another day and another group of
migrants attempts to cross the English
Channel
this time French authorities picked up
three men claiming to be Iranian before
handing them to the British Coast Guard
just off the coast of Dover it's thought
the conditions this Christmas have been
perfect for attempted crossings the last
two days I think most many people saw
that coming just because the unusually
calm weather I mean it was zero mile an
hour forecast on Christmas Day I mean
that's unheard of I do think you could
end up you know with someone drowning
really and not just because of the
weather but the boats they're coming
across in are made for cross in any
large body of water at all they're made
as tenders for gonna cross harbors
the backdrop to this is stark more than
120 migrants have attempted the crossing
in the last month this was just one of
the boats to be rescued in November 30
migrants were on board and yesterday 40
more including two children tried to
make it to Britain a number many say is
unprecedented we've come to expect
migrant crossings off the Kent coast in
the last few months I've been told time
and again that this is a crisis
situation and that's before the surge in
numbers of those desperately trying to
come here we've seen in the last few
days it's thought illegal criminal
smuggling gangs operating from the
beaches to the west of Calais are behind
the attempts and that the calm seas in a
perception that perhaps Christmas could
make for an easier crossing maybe the
reason we've seen such high numbers
charities say many of those coming here
are fleeing desperate circumstances
situation in Calais right now is
horrific it's getting colder and wetter
and people are sleeping rough with no
shelter from the elements so they are
desperate to get away the problem that
we have is that for the people who do
have a legal right to claim asylum in
the UK so the ones that have family
members there and do have a real legal
right to asylum the process is not
working there's no way for them to claim
that asylum I'm risking their lives on
lorries and on boats it's hard to know
what's drawing these numbers to make
such a dangerous journey but for many it
remains worth the risk
Allie Fortescue Sky News Dover